i am unbelievably blessed and lucky that
i've gotten to form these relationships
with folks that walk in so many
different kinds of shoes and so many
different like it's such a rich life
there's so many times damn i am so
grateful i'm getting to sit with you
right now learn from you and i also do
know in my heart of hearts
that these unbelievable friends that
i've made these people that i get to
share space with by putting that camera
as much as i inherently don't like it
like i don't like it i don't like my
friends to have to be in those
situations i don't but i also know that
like we need it like we need it right
now my kids need it i hate
the state of discourse in this country
right now i i hate how cowardly it is
how polarized it is how bombastic it is
and i hate the fact that the people with
the microphone are pandering i hate the
fact that they're just flag waving and
being all rah-rah and i know that the
reason why i want to do this in the
first place
was because i i had this idea of
bringing folks together and building
some bridges and the second i feel like
i'm doing this for any other reason is
the second i'm gonna stop doing this
[Music]
you